[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello
and welcome.
My name's Arun Nagarajan.
And this is an exciting
new episode of
Google Developers Live.
The folks that follow this
series, pretty regularly, I
work as part of the Apps Script
Developer Relations team.
And we're actually, here,
in Mountain View, today.
And we have some special guests
with us that are going
to be talking through some
exciting new products that
they work on, the Fusion Tables
product, specifically.
And throughout the series, we
will talk about how will you
use Apps Script and
other apps APIs to
integrate with Fusion Table.
So, like I said, my name
is Arun Nagarajan.
I'm with the Apps Script
Developer Relations Team.
And my guests are.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Hi,
I'm Sree Balakrishnan.
I manage the Fusion Tables
Development Team.
WARREN SHEN: And I'm
Warren Shen.
I'm a software engineer
building out the
Fusion Tables API.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's very
exciting to have core members
of the engineering team
on screen with us.
So Sree's actually going to
start off by explaining what
Fusion Tables is all about.
I think a lot of folks that
made Island may know a lot
more about apps and Apps Script
than Fusion Tables.
So we figure we'll take a couple
of minutes to just
explain what Fusion Tables
is all about.
And there are a couple slides
here that Sree will walk us
through as well.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN:
Thanks, Arun.
Well, for those of you who are
not familiar, Fusion tables is
a free, Google Drive
application.
It's been around for at
least two years now.
And it's really designed for
people who want to manage
data, but who are not expect
database administrators.
So we make it very easy for you
to upload large data sets,
up to about 100 megabytes.
We store it in the cloud, and
then give you a variety of
ways of visualizing that data
and analyzing that data and,
importantly for today's
discussion, being able to
access data through an API.
And I'll let Warren talk
about the API.
WARREN SHEN: Yes.
So right now we have a web app
that lets you upload the data
and edit it and publish it.
But our API lets you do
everything that you can do in
the UI programmatically.
So you can build apps that will
upload data, let users
edit the data, publish
the data.
You can adjust the styles and
templates, which is the things
that tell you how to display
a map or visualization.
You can edit those through the
API and keep your data up to
date and, as we'll talk about
today, keep it in sync with
other data sources.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Sorry,
I'll maybe talk
to the slide, here.
So this really shows a
very typical flow.
There are a number of compelling
applications that
people have created, where you
might have a database of
addresses or locations and some
properties about that,
like the number of people who
live at that place or the
amount of car traffic at a
particular intersection.
So you can create that data
as a CSV, import it.
And then we will be able to
geocode the addresses.
We will be able to analyze if
there are shapes in there.
We can handle KML shapes.
And then allow you to merge
that with other data.
This is the integrational fusion
step and then visualize
it, on a map, like
you can see here.
This is an example of something
created in--
I think it was.
I can't remember the name.
It was one of the government
agencies up in the state of
Washington.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Very cool.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: I think
this is looking at their
health outcomes.
And then the important thing,
now, is that, once you've got
it up and you can analyze the
data in the application, you
can now also access that
data through the API.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And
that's great.
It's not a siloed system.
You're actually able to interact
with it and exchange
information, without having
to always go to the UI.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: I think
the fact that you've got a UI
makes the API more
usable, right?
Because you don't always have to
go and query the API to see
whether your data is
correct or not.
You can go to the UI, use the
application, see whether your
data is correct, analyze it.
And then once it's correct,
then you know that your
application is going to work.
WARREN SHEN: And in the UI, we
have tools to explore your
data, to just do some quick
checks and make it very easy
to explore what you have
in the application,
in your data set.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And the API itself, the
documentation, I had a chance
to go through it.
I thought it was very
straightforward to use.
So could you talk a little bit
about what are some of the
critical things that people need
to know about the API?
What are some of the important
protocols and authentication
mechanisms that people
ought to know?
WARREN SHEN: Yes.
So the API is a RESTful API.
We have a collection of
different resources, which are
pretty straightforward,
table, column.
And then we have a query
feed, where you
can issue SQL queries.
You can edit and modify your
tables and columns, just say,
column names or data types for
the columns, RESTfully.
You can issue SQL queries.
And we have methods to edit,
delete, or import
data through the API.
Authentication is done
through OAuth2.
So if you have a private table,
then you will need
OAuth authentication
to edit the table
or to view the table.
For public tables, you don't
need OAuth2, you just see a
developer key.
In which case, you can allow
people to access the data--
not write to it but read
the data, without the
authentication.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And the documentation site,
for the folks that are not
familiar with it, is
developers.googl
e.com/fusiontables.
Very easy to find and there's
really a wealth of information
there to get started.
So from a point of Apps Script,
I'll do a quick
introduction as well, as to
what it is and what Apps
Script gives you.
The developer page for Apps
Script is developers.googl
e.com/apps-script.
And we actually just recently
launched a redone website,
with a lot more content and
better organization of
information that
we had as well.
And Apps Script is all about
doing more with Google Apps.
So taking the power of products
like Gmail, sites,
and Drive, docs, spreadsheets,
and so on and being able to
integrate them with each other,
with other third party
systems, other Google systems.
And being able to build the
workflows and little
applications, for your team or
your company, is something
that Apps Script is
really good at.
And to top it all off, you
build it in the cloud.
So you go to a browser
to write the code.
It's all JavaScript.
So you don't have to learn
a new language.
And the API is actually
super straightforward.
A lot of times, I find myself
just using the autocomplete to
build new things, rather than
even look at the reference
documentation.
So hopefully, you'll get a
flavor for that, today, as we
build some of the interesting
things in
the rest of the session.
So what I figured that we'll
do is showcase some of the
existing sample sets
of stuff that we've
had with Fusion Tables.
One of the ones that I think
really jumped at me was this
caterpillar information.
I can't really pronounce the--
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN:
Astraptes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Fulgerator?
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN:
Fulgerator.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Actually,
Arjun, just a quick,
30 second side story.
So this data set is important
to us, because it's part of
the founding of the product.
The team went to Costa Rica.
WARREN SHEN: [INAUDIBLE].
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So you guys
collected this data?
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Well, the
idea for the product came
from this visit to Costa Rica,
where we met a biologist who
were collecting data
on caterpillars.
And they wanted a tool to be
able to share that with other
scientists.
And that's where the idea
of the tool came from.
And so we like to use this.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah,
that's great.
And so always, from the genesis,
it had very much a
lot of data but built
to visualize?
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
WARREN SHEN: And share.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Part engineered
and share and
collaborate aspect to it.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: And
one of the things
that you can see here.
We like to show pictures,
as well, right?
So we make it easy for you to
put an image in a table, and
the image is rendered.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
Just by loading data in,
you immediately have an
application where you are able
to go in and say, show me all
female caterpillar species.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN:
Precisely right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And then also
be able to look at it as
cards, which I thought was a
nice way to browse through the
data that you had.
And it sounds like you can
actually customize it with
HTML and CSS as well.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN:
Exactly, yeah.
WARREN SHEN: [INAUDIBLE]
You can make it how you want.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And then the
geocoding and being able to
show that in a map.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Show where
they found it, where
they found these butterflies.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I got to
imagine, this was really
rewarding and fun for scientists
that are not
programmers--
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Exactly.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: To be
able to see this.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: They
didn't know anything about
database management or
anything like that.
They just needed to
know the data.
We make it easy for you
to get data up and do
useful things with it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Very good.
It makes a lot of sense.
I did not know that anecdote
about this being one of the
founding data sets to
power Fusion Tables.
That's a great little tidbit
that we learned here.
So that's great.
So I figured this is important,
for the folks that
have not seen what Fusion Tables
feels like, what it
looks like.
And just to showcase this
interaction with the API, what
I'll show you is, you can
actually take the table ID, go
into the Fusion Tables
documentation page, go to the
query page, down to the SQL, and
then you're able to test
the API right from within
the documentation.
So this is something you will
see in a lot of different
Google Developer products'
pages.
You have to authorize
yourself.
And I had already logged in, so
it didn't actually prompt
me which account or anything
like that.
I can just say, select
star from that table.
And anyone that's done any SQL,
that'll look very familiar.
And I can just hit execute.
And I should get back the
data That easily.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: I think
that will only work if the
table is public.
WARREN SHEN: Well, if you
authenticate, so.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I did
authenticate.
WARREN SHEN: Yeah, so if you
have private tables and you
click on the AOauth key, then
that will actually take care
of the OAuth.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN:
Oh, really?
WARREN SHEN: Yes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So that's one
of the nice powers of this.
You can actually preview what
you're about to build from
within the console.
So you learned something, too.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
WARREN SHEN: And the results
are in JSON.
It's native JSON, so you can
feed into whatever other.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
And the fact that it's JSON,
it's just a JavaScript Object,
makes it really easy to
work with Apps Script.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: You
have the option of also
taking it as CSV.
WARREN SHEN: So if you require
CSV, there's a parameter that
will specify what
output format.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, I
did see that as well.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: It's
JSON and JSONP, right?
WARREN SHEN: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, you can
have a callback as well.
I noticed that.
So what we figured, for the
rest of this demo, the
session, was to dive into one of
the demos that we built, a
little application that we
came up with, where, last
night, I just sat on my couch
and just wrote down a lot of
fake sample data.
And the idea was that, I'm a
school district, of about five
schools in my district, and,
as someone in charge of
tracking progress across the
district, I want to see the
grades, for a bunch of students,
across all these
different schools
and subjects.
And also we'll have a
representative, in each
school, that has to open a
spreadsheet and then enter in
those grades.
So the entry mechanism
is a spreadsheet.
And they can actually download
the grades there as well.
But then the visualization and
then the merging aspects are
in Fusion Tables, which gives
you a lot more power.
And I could also publish this
data, in a summary format,
such that other journalists and
data scientists could take
this data and use it as part
of their own research and
publications.
So the fact that it's in Fusion
Tables gives that
potential road map.
So like always, the code that
I'll be using is all on my
GitHub page.
So if you just go to
github.com/entaq, which is my
handle, and then Apps
Script, there's a
folder for Fusion Tables.
And the two necessary files
are right from there.
So this is this data set,
about 200 rows.
Like I said, five schools,
but I forget how
many rows per school.
But a small data to
prove the point.
All of this is completely
made up.
So we use student IDs here
and making up names.
But the ID is that this
could be as rich as
you want it to be.
So let's get started with just
a very small example of
extracting this data.
So for this, what I'll do is
first create a spreadsheet.
And I'll just call this
student grades.
And in order to put in scripts,
at a spreadsheet
level, you have to open the
Script Editor from the
spreadsheet itself.
So you got to Tools,
Script Editor.
[INAUDIBLE]
I'm not going to use any
of the templates.
I'll zoom in a little bit,
so you guys can see.
And I'll call this
load grades.
And I'm just going to copy
the code, for now.
But I'll take a second
to explain what
they do, what it does.
I'm just going to copy the raw
code here and save it and
rename this to the rowutils.
And this is the code that is--
rowutils, those that have done
any sort of scripting will
find this very familiar.
This is straight from our
documentation site.
What this does, basically, is
turns spreadsheet rows into a
JavaScript Object, so they
really easy to manipulate and
map and load and things
like that.
So I'll also copy the other
code, which actually does the
data exchange.
So I'll make the raw version
of this as well, so it's
easier to copy and paste.
I'll say, New Script File.
I'll say, loaddata.
The files names, actually,
don't matter.
It all kind of gets bundled
in together, when it gets
executed on the server side.
So I have to do a
couple things.
Warren mention that this
is OAuth based.
In this episode, we won't dive
too deep into the OAuth
process itself.
But you'll be able to follow
along everything
that you need to do.
And in our other episodes, with
the YouTube API and the
Salesforce API, we showed you
all that's necessary to set up
an OAuth setup from scratch.
So I'll go to
developer.google.com/console,
which takes you to the developer
console, where you
register your API as a project,
API project, and then
also get your OAuth2
client key.
So I'll say Create.
And you'll say Fusion
Tables GDL.
And that's going to create
the project.
And you need to give it
a few parameters.
So we want the Fusion
Tables API.
And then go to API Access.
And then you want to create
an OAuth2 client.
I'll call it Fusion
Tables GDL.
I like to have this
one memorized.
Save us some time,
google.com/apps-script images
script 128 dot PNG.
And then also, I'll use the same
URL for my homepage URL.
In this next step, what you do
need is to deploy the script
that you have, as a web
app, so you can
use that as a callback.
So this is a bit of a manual
process, for now, but this is
something that we're
definitely going
to make a lot easier.
But this is necessary
for the time being.
So you have to say the
version and deploy
it as the user running.
And that's the callback
URL that we have.
And go back into the console,
paste that in.
So this is the tedious step that
you have to go through
the very first time you set
up an OAuth2 project.
And now you'll get what is
the client [INAUDIBLE]
the client secret.
So this is the product
that I'll delete.
So you'll have to create
your own client
ID and client secret.
So I'll copy this.
And in the code itself, you'll
see placeholders where you'll
want to paste this in, your
client ID, your client secret,
and then your callback
URL, which is what I
had from right there.
And the whole purpose of this
is such that, you are not
specifying your password, to
this application that's
running that data, as you.
You're just delegating
your access to it.
And I need to save
it one more time.
Because I updated the code.
And then we should be able to
publish that and get started.
So I went fast.
Hopefully, you'll be able
to follow along.
But if not, all this code and
the details are available in
our prior GDLs.
So what I'll do now is run the
On Open function manually.
It doesn't have to be manual.
It could be when you reload
the spreadsheet as well.
So authorize this and run it.
So now, when I go into my
spreadsheet, there should be a
new menu item called
Fusion Tables.
So this showcases how you can
inject custom menu into a
spreadsheet as well.
So hopefully, you'll learn
ways to do that as well.
And the very first thing
I need to do is login.
So this is how I'm establishing
my OAuth2
identity and then also
storing the token.
So it's going to say, hey,
this application that I
defined earlier, in dot
console, is asking for
permission.
I say allow access.
And you can see that the scope
is very restricted.
All it can do is interact with
this fusion table object,
rather than a drive or Gmail or
anything else that might be
more sensitive.
And then I'm done.
And I come back now, and I say,
download from Fusion Tables.
So it's a menu, different
process.
It could be little icons and
all that stuff as well.
And there you have it.
So the data downloaded
from Fusion Tables.
And we only downloaded data
for PK Middle School.
So that's about 32 records of
data, including the header.
And I got automatically put
into the spreadsheet.
So that's a very simple flow
that I wanted to showcase.
What I can also do is, now,
I actually go ahead
and edit the grades.
So remember that student ID
1,001 has a grade of 40.
I'll go ahead and
change it to 45.
And one of the things I'm doing
is tagging the changed
column, so the program
can find it easily.
And then I'll change his
history grades to
90, crank it up.
So in this example, I'm
just updating grades.
But very easily, this example
could be adapted to adding new
grades as well, from a Google
form or from importing from
other systems as well.
And then what I can do is say,
Upload to Fusion Tables.
And this script, which I'll walk
through in a second, is
able to understand what records
changed, [INAUDIBLE]
IDs are, corresponding to that,
and then push those
changes up to the Fusion
Table, itself.
If I go into my student
record now.
So there's the 40 and 60.
And if I refresh this, that
should reflect the new
data of 45 and 90.
So that showed the round trip
of downloading data from a
Fusion Table, using the API,
after establishing identity,
and then also pushing
data back.
So that was a very, quick
starter, but, hopefully, you
saw that these systems
interoperate really well together.
And once you set up the
connection, data
can flow very freely.
All you need do is write the
logic for which cells map to
which Fusion Table columns
and vice versa.
And a lot of it could
be generalized, too.
So if any developers out there
want to write a generalized
framework that is smart enough
to look at the column names
and create the update, insert,
select statements
automatically, that'll
be great.
The community would be very
grateful for something like
that to get started with, rather
than someone like me
writing it from scratch.
So let's do a couple of things
that are kind of
Fusion Table specific.
So one of the nice things about
Fusion Tables is the
ability to merge in data.
So if I say, file merge, it'll
ask me, which table do you
want to merge in from?
So if you notice, in here, I
have a column for school.
But there's no address
associated with it.
Let's say that there is a
spreadsheet, somewhere,
perhaps in the real estate
team, that tracks the
addresses and particular details
about each school.
And as a teacher, I don't
necessarily have that.
And I could put it in manually,
but I'd rather merge
it in, such that any changes in
the main data set reflect
in the merged version.
I could say File, Merge and
pick that data set.
Catch up here.
I'm not sure what's going
on here, a lot of spin.
I'll just refresh this
one more time.
Go to Saved File Merge, there
it is, school locations.
I'm going to say Next.
And what that's going to do is
scan the data, in both the
different data sets, and say
which column do you want to
use as a source of match?
So I'm going to say, school here
and school on the right
side as well.
Think of it as a visual join,
in this case, for example.
I'm going to say Next.
And then it's adding in a new
column called location for me.
And this is actually cool.
Because what it does now is
creates a whole new Fusion
Table that is a fused version
of two different tables.
And I can say, View Tables.
And it'll name it as Merge of
Student Information Systems
and School Location.
Now I have a new column
called location.
And it already added in
a view that's a map.
So that's one of the, I think,
very impressive things about
Fusion Table is that it's smart
enough to see things
like location and address and
automatically geocode that.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
Sometimes, if you're uploading
a lot of rows, it takes a
while to geocode them all.
So you'll see a little
dialer that comes up.
But if it's just a
few, then it--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: In this example,
since I live and work
in New York, I just was able
to make up those fake
addresses better than
anything else.
But I thought that was really
brilliant, where partial,
incomplete addresses, like 34
W 42 or something even more
obscure, that only had zipcode,
119 Madison and
zipcode, all that became
a nice contextual map.
And over here, I can then
say, Filter by Grade.
And I can say, show me--
and I can throw in another
filter as well.
Let's say filter by subject.
So I can say, show me where
English grades are
between 90 and 95.
And you can see that two of
the schools disappear.
So these three schools, there
are a few students that are
achieving between 90 and 95%
grade on their English topic.
So we built a very simple
visualization
that allows me to.
And, obviously, for five
schools, not that impressive.
But when you have hundreds of
points on the map, you can
start seeing some clustering.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Well,
the thing is that you can
color the icons based on
the score as well.
WARREN SHEN: So you can
customize how the map looks
with different styling.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And all this
can be built, with the map,
with the API as well, right?
WARREN SHEN: Both the API and
the UI, you can do it, yes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So in
this example, I'm
just building it manually.
WARREN SHEN: But everything
you did here, you
can do with the API.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
really, really cool.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: And the
other thing that you can do
here is you can publish this.
And you'll get an embeddable
version of it, so something
that you can put into
your own site.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
Yeah, the publish aspect,
I think, is
really powerful as well.
Because it's not something
that is
restricted to just you.
It can be embedded into
a Google site.
It can be sent out as a
link in a newsletter.
So it's really good at spreading
the love there,
which is great.
Let me show you one other thing,
which is, now, we wrote
the system.
In the code, itself, you'll
see that it's a lot of
boilerplate stuff that manages
the login and stuff like that.
But the actual download
part is plain, run the
SQL, get the data.
And it's one call to get it
as a JavaScript Object.
And you just loop through
and add the rows.
The update uses a little trick
that allows you to track on
edit, based on the
trigger on edit.
And then you can just store, if
it's something that I care
for, if the grade column
is updated.
It is a pretty naive tracker,
but you can definitely improve
it and add a lot more
resilience to it.
But hopefully, this is giving
you some inspiration to do
things like this.
And then there's the code that
uploads and then logs what it
is uploading.
And then the rest is all just
the OAuth2 [? dance ?]
that needs to be maintained.
One of the other things, that
I talked about briefly, was
the ability to filter data.
And the idea here is that, if I
am the principal for school
A, I should only see grades
for school A.
In this, it's very insecure.
I put the code to filter in
the main class, itself.
But you can pull in libraries,
which allows you to silo this
out really nicely, the
logic for security.
But you can see that, at the
very end of it, I just have a
little JavaScript map object
that tracks the account
information to the
school name.
So what I can show here is, if
I take this spreadsheet--
and I'll just empty this out,
go to share, send it to
another account that I have,
and copy that URL.
Same spreadsheet, so all the
scripts come through as well.
Let me go to another window
I have here and
go into this tab.
So here, I'm logged in as a
arun.at.pyxis@gmail.com.
The other one was
arun.apps-script@gmail.com.
And the menu automatically
popped up, because that's
registered to the
On Open trigger.
And if I say, login here.
Because I do have to establish
my credentials as
this account now.
It takes a couple clicks.
Should be quick.
And then I can now
download data.
And this data comes from Short
Hills Prep, right?
So this is not something
that is the same.
It's not the same data
that the other
spreadsheet was able to fetch.
And from here, I can actually
upload data.
So I'll just change this to say
something really low, so
we can filter it out easily.
So student ID is 1,009.
And I'll say upload
to Fusion Tables.
And that should go through.
And just row road
goes through.
And whoa.
Well, let's see if
it went through.
There was an error
message there.
But now, when I come in here
and, first of all, just find
if there's any, for all
subjects, anything within 30
and 40 and 35, let's say.
Let's say 25.
And there should be
just one school.
And that came in.
Let's see, if I refresh this and
if I hit Find again, maybe
updated the same record.
But what I'm trying to show here
is the ability for the
data, that still gets pushed
to the original source gets
pushed into the merged
version as well.
So the source of record is still
the same, even though
you may be merging it and
visualizing downstream in
other systems.
So even after we created this
geospatial merged version,
when I was still pushing to
the main source of student
information, it's getting
trickled down automatically.
WARREN SHEN: It all gets
propagated throughout.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So you guys
take care of that.
And I'm not sure what
happened there.
Let's see if I can find
that student and see
if that data updated.
But some network error or
something like that.
But I can vouch for the
fact that it did work.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: You can
change it in here, too.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, I can
change it in here as well.
Yeah, that's another
way to do it.
So, hopefully, that
all made sense.
All this code is, of course,
available for you to start
playing around and get a sense
for what's possible in Fusion
Table, what's possible
in Apps Script.
The magic in Apps Script is
all using URL fetch, which
allows you call third
party systems.
And then if it's JSON, it's just
a JavaScript Object that
you can parse easily.
In this example, we integrated
with spreadsheets.
But it could be a Google site.
It could be a bunch of documents
that you have in
your drive.
It could be a Google Doc,
itself, so create a nice
summary report in a doc.
There are a lot of different
things that you can
really do with this.
So did this all make sense?
Anything that I forgot?
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: I just
want to mention that one of
the nice extensions that we
have to SQL is we have
geospatial queries to call.
So you can say, find me all
schools that are within a
certain distance of
this point or
contained within this polygon.
That's a functionality you'll
not find with a traditional
SQL database.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
And that's really where the
power of a lot of the systems
that we have, maps and the
ability to store a lot of
data, come together in a
powerful application.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN: Certainly,
right You can
imagine a mobile app developer
could get a lot
of use out of this.
So you might have a bunch of
data that has properties about
certain locations.
And then your app, on the mobile
device, can select the
ones that are near
to where you are.
So show me all the
information--
you'll just see the view of the
data that's within five
miles of where you are.
And that's a very simple thing
to do using our API.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And you can
just pass in latitude and
longitude and the coordinates?
WARREN SHEN: Yeah, there's
a function.
And then you [INAUDIBLE]
want it or the lat-long,
which are in the
geopoints that are--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
So our time is short.
I think we're coming
up on our time.
But we were able to scratch the
surface of what's possible
in the API.
And hopefully, you were able to
take a lot of what you saw
and learned and build
some really
interesting and cool things.
Do share with us on what
you have built.
There's some really good
resources on the Fusion Table
side of things.
WARREN SHEN: There's a user
group and Stack Overflow, get
questions answered.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
Yeah, the Stack Overflow
resource is actually great,
especially with the API, a great
place for developers to
help each other and the Google
Developers to monitor it.
Check out a lot of these talks
and workshops that the team
has given in the past.
A lot of videos and, I'm sure,
there's a lot of good code
here that you can start
with as well.
And there's a really interesting
set of examples,
that the team has shared, that
are from government sources,
from schools, from independent
journalists.
So certainly take a look at that
as well to learn more.
I can't wait to see what
you guys build.
Thank you very much
for joining in.
And thank you guys
WARREN SHEN: Thanks
for having us.
SREERAM BALAKRISHNAN:
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]